maybe I'll start the episode This Way
dead error that's just on our phones
yeah
I'm just I don't want to waste any of
the conversation I don't either and also
I'm sure you guys feel the same there's
always like a million emails and things
[Music]
there he is he's in the building
he's in the building
oh there he goes
what's known as a false start
We're not gonna be talking about
American people talk about it no I don't
mind I don't I don't mind
good morning good morning good morning
good morning
he's got it yeah
8 45 was the email 8 45 what we did say
to get tested for a night yeah
start a little early when everybody's
busy but we don't have to but we're not
go ahead
okay now we go silent again
[Laughter]
oh man
[Music]
now to be clear and fair to Glenn he is
six minutes seven minutes early yeah
right super early you're super early
you're super early I just didn't want
you to feel bad because I know how bad
you feel about this guy sure which the
fans will like you know what's that a
band shirt yeah and it's new
it's that's not that new no but I
haven't I haven't worn it that many
times I have two of them and I think I
got I think I grabbed the one that I
don't wear as much okay now notice that
you flipped up the cuff I've got a large
and a medium and this is the this is the
large this leaves a little long so the
sleeves are a little long on it so I
flipped the I flipped it a little bit
yeah I don't like it I don't like it
when this I wish that t-shirts were made
let's get into this
tell us what's wrong with t-shirts
t-shirts
get out the problem with shirts the
problems the problem with life is is
when you're the type of person who has a
[__] opinion about everything you
know when you have like a strong take on
like everything you're like I just wish
the t-shirts now this but in all
seriousness I I wish that t-shirts
sleeves were just a little shorter I
don't know it's I can't seem to find one
that is the sleeveless yeah you want
like a Vinnie barbarino look
I stopped going bitty barbarino I don't
need to go full yeah it's like literally
coach dad now but like you don't want
that you still want to be able to be
like I could work on this car if I need
to and you know not get grease on my mid
arm
[Music]
you were at the Super Bowl I was at the
uh correct the Super Bowl yeah now
that's an event uh held every year for
the for creeps and listeners who aren't
familiar with the uh the sport of
American football
um I think planning on doing it like
every year or I think that's the plan
yeah wow yeah for the foreseeable future
yes so then does in that regard then
like is there any point to it at all
well yes because every single person
that's on those teams represents that
town that they're from
yeah uh now I have I have an interesting
thing in my household where I have uh
one son who who has taken such great
interest in in in football sports in
general and he'll and he just absolutely
loves the NFL and he watches every game
he's both an Eagles fan and a Chargers
fan because he lives in Los Angeles and
so he's really embraced it I have
another Rams fan no likes the Chargers
uh and uh another song
[Laughter]
I have another son San Diego's team
another son who does not give a flying
[__] about the NFL watching football on
Sundays now he does watch soccer he and
I would get much Global football with me
yeah on okay on Sunday so but then he I
I brought him to the NFC Championship
Game and my one son was just all over it
and my other son was just sitting there
not truly not not caring at all he was
excited because we were excited but then
then he asked me subsequently
why do you care about this and I said I
don't know how to explain it can you
explain it actually can you try to
explain it because I can because I don't
I can't figure out I would love to care
about I actually do enjoy watching
football yeah I really do I I really
enjoy what I don't enjoy is the fact
that a one-hour game lasts four hours
well sure that's ridiculous I would say
I can explain it this way well now first
of all he does watch
football I'll call it soccer for our
audience let's call it soccer he watches
and he's a big fan of wrexham and he
watches soccer with me every Saturday
morning and he's so he gung-ho for
wrexham he just doesn't care about
American football I will say in terms of
caring
about professional sports and why you
should care about it or why people do
I've got another whole television series
that's about this very thing if you just
checked it out ah yeah you should check
you should check it out it's called
welcome I still care to watch it you
know what I mean I just don't care I
just don't care that's fair but if you
just check out the first five to ten
minutes you might see why other people
across the globe have embraced the
television series again growing up in
New England and with my buddies and
everyone was a Red Sox fan and so it has
been a bit of a bummer to be out in Los
Angeles and you lose a little bit of
that even though computers and they love
the Lakers and they love it it's called
maybe the Rams that community on just
the eye of the sports bars and the the
Gathering I think that's the problem for
me having grown up all over the world
and and not even always even in the
United States and then settling in a
state that doesn't have any great
professional sports teams like Alabama
uh you could Roll Tide what's up
professional sports no I know but still
that's a that's it no it definitely is a
professional sports team sure well yeah
to make a shitload of money for their
there's an argument for the organisms
for the Georgia Bulldogs are are an NFL
team could beat half the NFL teams well
that now see why hasn't that been done
it's just an exhibition match you know
the uh the top NFL team versus well
buddy I got a whole sport to sell you
it's called soccer here in the United
States but but across and that very
thing that you just said does exist
that's the beauty of the English
football system we get it you have a
football team you have a soccer no but
what I'm saying is that you you have
lower league teams that play higher
League teams and you you see that very
thing happen yeah you like boxing and
the idea that there could be an upset
that some Scrappy kid from the middle of
nowhere can Beat the Champ I like that I
mean that's Rocky
that's Rocky okay
that's every uh sports movie ever made
but even Alabama I was there from like
10 to 18 you know and I was an Auburn
fan while I was there but then once I
left literally nobody gave a [__] when I
where I went to college nobody cared
about college football nobody it was all
about NFL football and I was like yeah
but I haven't really been in it I don't
know but I mean I did grow up I was a I
was a Raiders fan growing up and uh and
a 49 I don't know how you can be a 49ers
fan and a Raiders fan but I was a 49er
could be whatever you want pal well okay
thanks man yeah appreciate that
appreciate the permission um
but then I just yeah I don't know man I
can't well it's also it's also like if
the game was well it's two hours right
yeah with commercials I think I'd be
more likely to watch it it's just about
the finding the story the story that you
identify with and the thing that you
fall in love with in the same way that
you could go and watch a play that's 20
minutes long that sucks and want to
leave after 10 minutes or you could
watch I've heard you talk about a a
four-hour play that you were riveted by
oh God yeah right exactly Amazing
Story you care you care but see that's a
fun place you gotta find reasons yes 100
and that's why that's why all those
shows like all those competition shows
like American Idol and stuff it's all
about the it's the story it's not like
yes the singing is extraordinary but it
doesn't mean anything if you don't know
the person's background and they don't
you know have a compelling and I got a
whole show of a whole series for you
it's it's on yeah it's always sunny we
cover that yeah we do cover that on It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia the the
show that we should really be here to
talk about yeah uh you know uh we where
we talk about the reasons why politician
shows work why people watch sports and
into It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
can I tell you I have I have a good
segue I think I have a good sunny I
really I have a good transition the
whole time well I I have a good
transition can I just say one more thing
one of I think that's one of the things
I always really responded to when it
came to boxing
was it's two people willing to get in
the most physically like exhausting
sport you know MMA certainly but like
you know just getting your just pounding
someone and getting pounded by somebody
and there's no teammates to rely upon
you know what I mean yes you've got your
coaches you've got your cut man you got
you know all this but like
just
the savagery of one person versus
another one with intent to kill that's
what gets you off that's what gets you
now if there was like sort of I could
get behind that a gladiator sort of
style where there was like three or four
of them and the lion loose
sounds good too okay so it's not you're
you're into the team if I know it's a
bad story you know the backstory you're
like so there's too many people on the
football team I I can't memorize
everybody's backstory I don't have time
for that okay well let's speed it up get
rid of the refs just let the boys fight
it out just play it out you know what I
mean no penalty is just like whatever
just bash bash your way up and down the
field you know yeah no one's upset about
you know whistles and calls just just no
rest just the clock has started you know
the rules go that would have helped me
out this weekend that would have helped
me out well there was one particular
call at the end of the game
that was brutal now you're talking about
the holding call yes but you can't
complain about it they shouldn't have
been in there in a position in the first
place
um yeah but that's a that's a that's a
brutal game-changing it's not the reason
that they lost it's just it would have
been more fun to see the eagles with the
ball at the end of the game with down
three instead of down seven with six
seconds left yeah yeah but 100 that's
the sport and I'll say that I was pretty
bummed of course
um it was a great season now thus far
this year I've watched the teams that I
love and follow lose come in second
place which is essential which is losing
uh in the championship game or there or
the version thereof
the fa uh trophy final the league uh
final uh in in the EPL
um or the English system uh the Phillies
lose the World Series the Philadelphia
Union lose the MLS Cup and now the
Eagles losing the Super Bowl all in
person
well listen uh get used to it buddy I
mean It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
is the second place of TV shows oh I
think we're like the 15th Place yeah
okay I was trying to give us ourselves
we're number one in one category well
you can't win if they don't let you in
the competition you know what I mean
high five from over on the side of the
table yeah yeah yeah yeah they're scared
to fight the street fighter you know but
my transition is that I was pretty you
know I was pretty bummed I came home
um Leo was pretty bummed I took my son
Leo
and we got home and then I realized oh
we have this the podcast tomorrow that's
something to look forward to and I get
to watch an episode of Sunny so I
thought okay I'll cheer him up he gets
to watch very few episodes of Sunny not
quite old enough yet but we just popped
it in and we watched it and man this
episode is so funny are you kid friendly
and kid friendly safe this one it made
me very happy we were laughing I'll I'll
point out a couple of areas where he
laughed out loud because it's
interesting to see what attention is how
a 10 year old can laugh and when I was
laughing as hard as I've ever laughed at
this show let me let me guess the the
laugh out loud say Danny hanging himself
and then popping up and said don't try
to stop me
don't try to stop me oh my God that was
me laughing Leo was very confused at
that okay because he didn't quite
understand and he cut his face knife
Danny cutting he's bigger with it with a
knife
I mean we were both he was Leo was
laughing so hard and then I was laughing
at that and then him laughing that I
started crying laughing at him and then
that got him going so good I got big
Chris Farley Vibes off of that just uh
yeah it's his oh yeah oh God yeah yeah
they're like little booze yeah he moves
yeah like a little but no but then but
then him taking his briefcase into the
bathroom he hadn't going to hand
himself again
laugh out loud just some turns man
you guys conversations which don't have
like crazy twists and turns but are very
very just funny conversations well this
is where we can talk a little bit about
the business of making the television
series because that's what we really got
boned in that circumstance what we may
have mentioned this on the podcast but
uh before but we'll bring it up again
since this is the episode ad sales
really boned us on this one yeah I
remember yeah big time well they reached
out to us and said would you be
interested in doing some kind of product
placement which we've done in the past
sure right cores uh uh actually we've
done a ton of them
um and they said Dave and Busters and we
said sure what it would be funny if we
just actually didn't just say Dave and
Buster's but like made an episode about
yeah kind of making fun of it but also
kind of embracing it and recognizing
everything it wasn't also like a light
suggestion we were early in our game and
it was more like guys you have to do
this because Dave and Buster's is like
not going to give the show a lot of
money and it was like of course we can't
force you but we really strongly suggest
you find a way to work it into an
episode and we're like oh we're smart
guys we can do something and talk about
Dave and Busters and have it be fun I
think we also found it like I you know
it's always funny when you have make the
unexpected choice of like the characters
actually like really respecting and
loving yeah
also we thought well that's a really
funny place for us to have an episode so
great let's do it yes yeah so so we we
had that going and we and we made that
and it's a business and we they we
needed to keep making the show and they
came to us and said we need to keep
paying for the show would you guys help
us out so sure so but what we didn't
know was that they also made a massive
ad sales buy right so they were for
their right so what was happening was
yes they were airing it was the sole
sponsor of the evening yeah and you
would you were watching the show where
the characters are talking about Dave
and Busters then they would cut to a
commercial and the first commercial you
would see is a Dave and Buster's
commercial yeah and people went below
people were rightfully pissed off and
like
you know like now if you go watch that
in streaming or however you're finding
the show big deal right you like it
they're in Dave and Busters it's funny
but yeah man combine it with a Dave and
Buster's commercial every yeah that that
seems like foolish on their on their
part like you're actually getting less
for for your money in that sense because
you're you're enraging people yeah
you're enraging people yeah yes and that
is what happened so we so I remember a
bunch of funk frantic phone calls
maybe it wasn't even that night it was
the next day we saw each other and and
then and then we called FX and we were
like what the [__] like you you
completely like hung us out to dry you
asked us to be your good partner and
then you did something like that and to
their credit they came back and said it
was just a miscommunication and a
mistake and so well and I want to be
clear I mean you know to be clear to the
audience this uh when a show does
product placement the money goes to the
network so it doesn't go into the pot
that we don't make that money we don't
make any money off of that including the
AdSense no we don't make any of that
none of that but none of that but what
it does is it justifies the cost of
making the show for the network it's
indirectly yeah they're more likely to
continue licensing the show because
they're not spending as much and yeah I
was doing a uh uh golf tournament thing
like and uh
and this there was a guy there and I
guess his job is like hooking people up
and connecting celebrities with things I
don't know he was not affiliated with me
he was really with someone else
perfectly nice guy I'm not totally
trying to drag him but he kept saying to
Mary Elizabeth and I you know if you
want I can you know I can get you guys
into Dave and Buster's and I was
thinking like
ah I can get in today
you walk right yeah yeah I didn't call
him I just couldn't take anybody yeah
you you're being polite you're like huh
yeah oh thanks man thanks so much she's
like wait wait you profusely thanked him
for uh yeah okay yeah you're just trying
to yeah you just wanna I don't want to
lean into it you know sure but uh
he kept doing it and uh kept you know
frequently be like guys let me know you
know if you need that Dave and Buster's
hook up I'm like what on Earth what on
Earth I can get into Dave and Busters I
don't know we never figured it out I let
it I let it were going to say that you
finally figured out what the hell he was
talking about like he's going to let you
back I think his thing was like he knows
people you can get your tickets like
good tickets to Lakers or something I
don't know I notice if you want to get
me an unlimited power card
and I'll have that conversation I'll
have that conversation maybe that's what
he meant maybe that's what he meant
maybe that's that's right then lead with
that don't tell me you can get me into
Dave and Busters yeah because I can get
in myself I've got legs anybody can get
into that Busters you know yeah I was
thinking last night of how many I used
the door we've talked about how many
presidential terms the show uh has seen
but I was thinking last night in terms
of the the cyclical nature of them of
the markets how many how many economic
upswings and downturns have we gone
through and it's it's it's really two
major uh major
recessions although I don't know that we
can consider ourselves in a recession
quite yet right now but but like it was
like Peak Market when we started it was
like getting up into like 2007 yeah then
a crash then it came back and now we're
we're in an inflation a period of
inflation right now yes which we may or
may also not be dealing with on the show
well we are well yeah okay we are we can
talk about it right um yeah that's not
gonna spoil anything
um you don't know how we deal with it
yeah
you don't know you don't know you have
to tune in stupid we know
so what else so the recession episode
yeah uh the conversation's about about
uh not understanding how money works not
understanding how Economics work
finances work uh all the all those were
very funny conversations to write and
conceive of like I especially that that
that last speech that we have where you
know we're trying to figure out how the
money circulates and how how a
self-sustaining economy works and
not understand not and then born out of
a bunch of comedy writers in a room like
all asking each other like wait how does
it actually how does it work realizing
there was nobody that took an economics
class no no we're here to be fine
something like this yeah it's just
something like the money Meg could you
explain to us
I tell you one thing I was right about
months and months and months ago on this
podcast and I I feel like I got dragged
a little bit for saying it though but
like when the gas prices went through
the roof and I was like it's insane I'd
like just just charge less for gas like
uh and maybe as an oil company you don't
profit as much they you know they just
release their profits and they're like
oh it's astronomical yeah like guys we
did fantastic we did great killing it
they're killing yeah people are like I
try to know how it works yes I do wait
who who's dragging you people online
wait a second people online people
online people online
I was right they're just taking your
money they heard it here guys you were
wrong and Charlie was right so shut the
[__] shut the [__] up and stop paying so
much if you don't know the shot then
don't take the [__] shot now these
guys don't pay for gas yeah to be clear
neither does electric cars uh now Megan
how does the economy work
I also have no idea how the economy
works that's why I'm asking because I do
feel like it works with greed and uh
wealth and greed creates wealth and uh
when too much greed creates too much
wealth and no one else as well then
they're like oh now we go I got a little
bit of an issue and uh let's charge
let's charge more for sure what you're
describing is a revolution but not an
economy the meek shall inheritance wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
the meek shall inherit the earth oh [__]
yeah Cletus
so you don't want to be up here on this
on top of this mountain on this on this
gold house okay right because the meek
shall inherit the earth so
that's how the economy Works isn't it
like we control the masses through
religion yeah yeah we keep the make me
let's make it poor or is Meek just like
kind of like scared of loud noises you
know I I
it's not a very flattering term yeah
yeah yeah you don't want to be known as
a Meek man yeah and it's really close to
mink so I think of like a little animal
like a little mink yeah dude we know
something so much about the economy see
[Music]
guys I'm trying to hire someone to do
press for me and I can't find the right
person you mean like a publicist yeah uh
no ideally someone who just like does it
for me so I don't have to you know I
give them the talking points to hit and
I say you know pretend you're me and
then you know then I go tell them to hit
those points it sounds like you're the
publicist then uh no I'm just the guy at
home
not doing all the Press
what are the biggest hiring challenges
of 2023 is uh standing out to top
candidates yeah you want to stand out
well then you should use zip recruiter
zip recruiters technology sends you
great candidates and makes it easy for
them to apply to your job instead of
filling out a long application they can
learn all about you and apply with just
a click okay so but you in the in your
situation that you were describing
Charlie you would need someone who looks
like you right like a press uh somebody
to do the pr a double a double yeah
ideally yeah yeah they do let you set
attention grabbing labels on
ZipRecruiter I don't know if you guys
know this but like you can put like
urgent training provided you know remote
and more all kinds of labels you know
maybe you can set uh doppelganger too
maybe you can do that maybe you know you
can find out for free right now at
ziprecruiter.com get your job noticed by
the best and brightest candidates with
ZipRecruiter four out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day that's
impressive so see for yourself go to
this exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com
sunny again that's ziprecruiter.com
s-u-n-n-y ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire so smart
this show is sponsored by betterhelp an
online therapy service that can help you
feel like your best self we've heard
when Charlie and Glenn feel like they're
best selves on the golf course and after
a cold shower but Rob when do you feel
like your best self uh after rexima
clinch is a big match ah and clinch a
match is uh that's Welsh for win a game
yes well that's English but uh yes uh of
course that's never a guarantee that
they're going to clinch sometimes you're
supposed to win and you don't sometimes
you're not supposed to win and you do oh
is this all to say you wish there was
some kind of sports therapy to help you
cope with the stress of owning a
football club I'm all for therapy and if
the licensed professionals on betterhelp
have positive coping skills for tough
matches
like the Super Bowl by all means you've
tried it you guys have tried it right oh
yeah absolutely yeah I've tried it and
my dilemma wasn't really about clinching
soccer matches but still I found it very
straightforward and beneficial plus it's
flexible affordable and entirely online
so when I needed an expert to work with
me I was always able to find someone
guys if you want a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com sunny today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash sunny
[Applause]
speaking of things that you don't know
in this episode there's a classic quote
that doesn't sound right but I don't
know enough about stars to dispute it
yes yeah
that was Robert Zell I remember him yeah
pitching or writing that line of me like
that is so good yes because Charlie
thinks that he burns trash but turns
into smoke which turns into Stars yeah
yeah that's a good one
um we shot a lot of this one in Philly
yeah all that stuff the with you being
crab people and the Dave and Busters was
in Philly
yeah that's good Merlot You're Gonna
Want to keep those coming yeah it might
be a little cheaper if he's going with a
bottle of wine instead of chugging the
individual glasses yeah maybe leave the
Judgment back in the kitchen because
there's a little bit of a look at
judgment on your face just go grab them
and okay no problem all right thank you
great oh she's terrific like her yeah
yeah and she but she must have been
Sabrina Sabrina
she was great she nailed it yeah she did
um
I like I do like that we stained our our
mouths yeah yeah purple
that was that may even the first time we
did that and that comes back quite a bit
oh right Leah loved that that killed
with the 10 year olds he was like are
you wearing lipstick and I said No it's
it's from the red wine and he was like
the red wine makes your lips red I'm
like well if you drink enough of it and
he's like you guys drank so much that's
so funny I'm like wow
yes and it's funny in this contest
I do like that I do like that we've we
we sense some judgment we I like opening
the scene with us just chugging the line
and then and then and then she's telling
us that it's cheaper to just buy a
bottle and we don't want to hear any
sacks
you know I bet that we had shot the uh
intervention episode first and then we
went down to Philly to do the Philly
shoot and we were like it was so funny
to have those red teeth I think you're
right yeah I think you're right I think
we and we realized we're like well we've
already established that we're we're
drinking lots of red wine we have that
and it's funny so let's let's go for it
yeah yeah we would have gone to Philly
at the end we always win at the end yeah
yeah we'd shoot everything in LA and
then the last week I'm not telling you
guys I'm telling the audience the we
would check how many miles since we got
back to that like exactly I can just be
worried that Rob's gonna jump in and be
like I know this you're telling me when
we used to shoot in Philly
remember that you want to reload that
I'll reitigate that yeah
once again it has nothing to do it's the
way that you're positioned
come on
it's a seething
man oh Lord Jack back in this episode
for the first time since season one
right what made you guys decide to bring
Uncle Jack this is so damn funny and why
did it take so long any chance why did
it take so long I was thinking that I
was like but is this the wait is this
the first time yeah season one yeah
that's what you were just that's crazy I
don't know why maybe we just
hadn't thought of where he would fit in
an episode or whatever it is yeah yeah
um I thought maybe you guys might like
to watch the blooper of him and Charlie
uh I'm talking about I would love to
yeah
the memory of Charlie doing something in
this episode that he that he doesn't do
what is it and then I thought maybe is
it it's probably in the bloopers it's
probably the bloopers him him just
pointing to Uncle Jack yeah oh yeah yeah
okay I was just waiting for that moment
and then it didn't happen
just you me and you pounding around
getting crazy and nuts and all sorts of
things
come on seriously
staying in it she kills me too man what
if we set up your room just like it was
when you were a kid yeah with tats in a
dividing line
all improvised
remember when I slept on this I remember
every time
bunnies
I'm a bunny you're a bunny snuggle
snuggle she's killing it I survived my
childhood by the skin of my teeth
[Laughter]
how are you boys
boys
[Laughter]
oh he's so good okay she's so good as
well yeah she's just in it in it yeah
total Pros now this was hard to explain
to Leo because I was laughing so hard
and he he was like well so why is funny
and I was like well because the older
man is inappropriate he's just being
inappropriate and Leo's like well how
why is he inappropriate like should they
not be because they talk about wrestling
he just wants to have a good time with
his nephew right and at some point he
says something about wrestling and how
you guys are going to wrestle and and
you said but Uncle like uncles don't
wrestle with their with their nephews
and and Leo was like why can't uncles
yeah wrestle with nephews and I was like
well the next scene is starting so let's
just yeah
it's just some uncles Leo some uncles
aren't shouldn't be allowed
the episode is maybe passable or
appropriate I'm like well this yeah okay
there's this scene yeah well this is why
I don't watch the show with my kids yeah
yeah yeah this is pretty cool this one's
this is a close one it had some big
laugh out loud moments yeah him swinging
on that thing the visual gag of that of
the Noose yeah it's great yeah also
falls in the category of Danny just
being up for anything anything yeah I
mean how old was he there he was I don't
know I mean
67. yeah late 60s late 68. yeah I mean
he's up for it's not like we actually
hung him
it's uncomfortable it's very
uncomfortable that harness goes up
around it goes up around your crotch
yeah and then but I remember we had to
like work with it because it didn't seem
like
you know it suspends you by your waste
and then you kind of start to tilt
forward and then doesn't look like the
pressure's on your neck so Danny had to
kind of like hoist his weight forward so
that his head could go back so that it
looked like he was hanging and then
lower his chin but then it was a funny
position to be in when he looked up and
said don't try to stop him and then
those kicks he does at the end like he's
trying to dig in Chinese
time's tough huh
[__] that was another Roselle line I
remember
I really like Charlie's sort of like
manic energy in this episode and there's
one specific shot where you guys are
like we're gonna give you a chance you
tell Dee and Charlie we're going to give
you a chance to justify your jobs and
you do this like I'm so excited to like
prove to you like that that energy and
then Rob's just enjoying it like it felt
like you were like out of character just
watching him being like I like this this
guy this guy he's up for it okay we're
gonna get a show
is so funny too we should be like you
guys think you're gonna go to Dave and
Buster's and I just go ah you know and
D's going what and then we just like
hard cut out remember that being the
ending I I rewounded because I was like
sure we had there was a horror written
and it just absolutely flat and we're
like just go out there I just don't
remember I don't remember that episode
ending that way
I was watching that being like okay wait
how's it going to end I don't I can't
remember I thought I'd accidentally hit
the fast forward button or something
like yeah it was a little too abrupt for
me I don't know I thought it was
joyfully abrupt where I was like oh oh
great that's great like sometimes it's
not fun when we tuck it in too much and
then it's like
it feels too neat you know tuck it in
too much I like that yeah yeah I like
that yeah it's like you just go to bed
just slam the door in the episode
yeah yell at it to go to bed and slam
the door on it kind of bad
Danny with the vacuum cleaner
and we had written it one way and he
kept saying it
uh
because it doesn't have any Muffler
right and we probably think we'd written
Like You Know cover your hands just
sucker ain't got no Muffler and he
wouldn't say ain't got no mm-hmm
he used to refuse to to to say that we
would write it in the script all the
time like it wasn't intentional it
wasn't like I'm not I don't think Frank
talks like this it's just that he would
you know we're moving fast and you're
learning things on the Fly and his mind
would just translate it to better
English it was a good choice too to to
Really ramp up the sound of the uh of
that thing and make it insanely loud and
then put subtitles they were like
screaming yeah especially Caitlyn
screaming you jerk jerk yeah that's
great I was going to ask if you guys
have ever been fired from a job I don't
know if we've talked about that have you
ever been fired I've ever been fired I
feel like you did so did we not talk
about that
uh what having been fired haven't been
fired
I've been edited out of various movies
and television shows that's a form of
firing have we talked about that that
we've talked about but yeah yeah
uh really taken the wind out of a lot of
people's sales but instead it just made
your wind blow harder it just fueled my
fire just fuel we just made the chip on
the shoulder just a little bit larger
that's right yeah
I remember used to I remember when we
were younger when we were young men
in our 20s and you would say you you
used to tell me that like you had this
like little demon that would wake you up
in the mornings
that's basically that like the thing get
up well no he was so yeah the thing that
would get him out of bed was this
because this little demon voice in your
head that was basically telling you that
you were lazy that you were a piece of
[__] that you weren't doing enough that
you were uh yeah
get up and write five screen plays fresh
make a joke Facebook 17 seconds
[Laughter]
a version of that still there I but I
always found it I never found it
necessarily destructive I found it kind
of uh
but it can very easily describe and
Comics I love you you lazy son of a
[__] now get up yeah it was more like
that okay it was more like it was an
extension of myself not some exterior
being that was saying that I was
unworthy or something it's Meredith
Burgess for me it's more it's more Super
narrative
thunder today yeah his name was Meredith
yeah that's interesting
his name is Burgess
[Laughter]
you know what John Wayne's name was uh
no I don't what his real name Wayne's
real name
I don't know what Marion
oh Marion Johnson Marion no I don't
remember what his last I don't think it
might be Marian Wayne
Morris Marion Morrison which by the way
is an awesome name too Marion Morrison
not as awesome as John Wayne yeah I'm
surprised he didn't go with just the
Robert Morrison but I guess if John
Wayne's on the table you're gonna say
that yeah yeah yeah yeah did now did
those guys they did like did he come up
with that himself was he like I feel
like I'm a John Wayne type I don't know
that's not good that's right that's how
he did it yeah it was back in the day
when the studio once credited as Duke
Morrison everybody called him Duke
apparently that was what everybody the
duke or dude right there's like some
studio guys back in the days like listen
here we're gonna call you this you know
you're gonna do 10 pictures for us but I
like the idea that pay a thousand
dollars that Marion Morrison sounded too
ethnic that was the thing they wanted to
make everything seem as like waspy as
possible like John Wayne just feels like
an American you know they were like no
juice no Irish no Italians like let's
just keep it like right down the middle
yeah yeah you can be those things but
your name can't indicate as much yes
right Fox Studio Chief Winfield Sheehan
rejected the his name as it sounded to
Italian and then a director Raul wash
Walsh who cast John Wayne and stuff
um suggested John Wayne Uh because it
sounded more less Italian I guess kind
of makes John Wayne seem like a little
bit of a [__]
didn't stand up for his own name his own
Heritage he could have said God damn it
I'm Marion Morrison and that's all there
is to it you know and instead he was
like I'll do whatever you say boss
[__] John that's not the John Wayne I
know and remember yeah yeah he was an
actor
I used to do Shakespeare yeah exactly do
I sing and dance in this picture or not
just how did John Wayne become an actor
did he start in the did he start was he
doing he was a he went to USC which is
odd did he play football yeah he was he
was yeah he was an actor that sounds
right he's huge he was like six five or
something six four six five right and he
was an athlete and then he was injured
and lost his athletic scholarship and
had to leave the university I thought
you're gonna say lost his knee or
something you know by the way back in
the back in the day when you got a
scholarship to play a sport and then if
you got injured they were like okay get
the [__] out can you imagine that can
you imagine that just because you tore
your your ACL you're halfway through
your education and they're like yeah you
know that thing we brought you in for
you can't do it anymore so you gotta go
yeah that's incredible yeah they got rid
of that sorry Marion you're out of here
he broke his collarbone which as we all
know is a really cool injury that's
pretty [__] sweet dude yeah did he do
it did he do it shredding yeah
body surfing accident
wow that's pretty cool wait wait John
wait
Morrison yes when he was attending the
USC
um had a broken collarbone which
curtailed his athletic career he later
noted that he was too terrified of Jones
who is his coach at the time of Jones's
reaction to reveal the actual cause of
his injury a body-surfing accident why
was that kid it's like a pansy sport I
mean I think it was probably like you
shouldn't be doing dangerous things
instead of people
when we need you out here but body
shredding bones not really that [__]
you can't take it you're doing it off
how are you gonna take on the UCLA
football team that's right now like
Crimson Tide how do you break your
collar but do you think he's body
surfing with his arms behind let me tell
you
manage
those things are breaking right into
this shows
there's a heavy pitch bro bro yeah bro
bro John that's how Marion Morrison used
to talk yeah it's like dude dude dude I
was [__] shredded
seen our ocean Gnar okay I was totally
shredding ocean and I was like let me do
one where my hands aren't here but
they're like here dude
there's a crazy [__] Shore Break
Marion you shouldn't do it bro Marion
you should not be in this wave Brother
Bear Marion this is not your wave
Marion was like [__] that dude ain't no
puss and then he [__] shredded it and
sure enough snapped his car
what am I gonna do now I can't even be
an actor I sound too Italiano
[Laughter]
everybody's gonna think I'm Italian dude
I can't play football I can't be in the
mood Giants will never thrive in movie
pictures
[Music]
guys
today is a very special day
it's President's Day which serves as a
humbling patriotic reminder
of one thing in particular how quickly
Are Presidents AIDS that's right wow
yeah look at uh Thomas Jefferson you
know he was only 53 when he was elected
but you know you look at any portrait
like his hair is so gray so white
again well Thomas Jefferson wore wig it
was like it was like one of those yeah
people were people were wigs he chose
gray he was choosing gray and white why
would anyone do that no clue but on this
President's Day we are supported by
athletic greens which makes no claims
about preserving your natural hair color
but does help keep your body ship shape
so you don't age prematurely in one
delicious scoop of their green powder
ag1 you are absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Foods sourced
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens it
also supports better gut health better
sleep and an optimized immune system all
factors that affect your body's aging I
use ag1 every single day and I feel
significantly Less Old than a U.S
president yeah and all I'm saying is
like if I had to wear a wig I would go
with like Tommy Lee and Motley Crue you
know not Thomas Jefferson I want to go
with like an old man white wig or what
about Tommy Lee Jones to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticreens.com sunny again that's
athleticgreens.com Sunny to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
[Music]
guys uh also on topic here
what's going on with shooting all the
[__] out of the sky right we're just
we're just blasting [__] out of the sky
left and right yeah I think uh you know
we just don't want to be seen as the
kind of people that will allow trash to
just float around in the sky yeah you
know some aliens or oh five balloons
it's a little listen I I was listening
to a whole thing on the news this
morning about it and they were talking
about like well it was just it's very
very likely that it was just it's just
you know apparently there's a lot of
debris just floating around in the sky
and I'm like
uh
there's gravity so no unless it's a
[__] plastic bag what are we talking
about plastic bags on this guy I'm like
[__] [__] fully formed octagons that
are flying around in the sky just I ass
just [__] trash like what are you
talking about yeah no Things fall from
the sky they don't float around I don't
know I don't know I don't know enough
about this stuff this guy's dispute it I
think it's safe to say that uh as long
as gravity still exists things were
gonna are gonna fall unless they're not
but because if something's if
something's waving around the sky and it
looks like a [__] jellyfish it's
probably not a spy balloon you know what
I mean it's just a plastic bag you're
not going to shoot a plastic bag down
with a missile you're just not
if you're a good shot you are if
anything's over my skies I shoot it down
God damn it it's pretty good
um if you did if you were the one who
saw an alien spacecraft like about to
land and you had the ability to either
shoot it out of the sky or let it land
what would you pick
I mean well definitely let it land you
got to let it land right yes you're
responsible for the complete destruction
of humanity as we know it because it's
worth the evolution if it's figured out
how to fly here it's going to be yeah
there's vastly support where it came
from yeah right yeah but we figured out
stuff should be that it's up to no good
we're not that smart what if he's just
here on what if he's just here to
[__] body surf what if he just wants
to body surf nard ocean Gnar oh man if I
had a collarbone I would have just
broken it
good thing I'm mostly liquid
just jelly people jelly people uh you
know from the skies that want to shred
ocean Gnar yeah or if that may be all
they are right it's just
jelly people from another planet that
want to shred Gnar on our planet and we
keep shooting them down we're like
they're just like yeah [__] man could be
whatever we should write that movie we
don't want more trash in the ocean
um jelly people jelly people jelly
people I can go see that for sure
[Laughter]
you know spy balloons so you don't want
to postulate what may what may be up
there you you do you guys don't wanna I
have no idea it's really interesting
letting us know if I'm being honest I
have I have checked out of the new cycle
for the last few days is that right well
this the circus of the of the Super Bowl
in combo with me just spending three
solid days with my son and just having a
good time and I was like oh [__] it I'm
not gonna I don't care I don't care
about any of that [__] and now I'm
hearing people talk about the and yeah I
don't know it's probably Space trash
maybe it's aliens I'll find out in a few
days I'm getting too lazy to read the
full articles you know I'm like seeing
the headline and then I'm skimming for
like any pertinent information but come
on what are we doing spy blue alien yeah
give me a alien alien alien no alien all
right [__] it yeah right you're just
skimming the article looking for the
word alien yeah and if you don't see it
yeah he's talking about debris and I
want something entertaining to happen
you know yeah I saw my cat fight off a
hawk all right I will save that from the
next one okay I want to hear about this
well okay so my cat is the baddest
[__] the cats are insane well by
the way by the way you described your
cat that way but all outdoor cats are
this way just say we're clear Jack Bauer
style Cat we're talking about that is a
cat that grew up on the streets yes
Street Cats the outdoor cats
before on the podcast we then made him
an indoor cat for about two weeks and he
just would sit by the window and just
beg to go out and I was like this cat
he we are now denying him the life that
he wants to live that's right let's keep
him out during the day let him do
whatever he wants and then at night
we'll bring him in because just covered
in [__] blood every night when you
bring him in God damn he is covered in
blood three out of the seven days well
he's white he's white he's like a white
he's a beautiful white he's like he he's
the most graceful creature that's ever
been a white cat what a find yeah yeah
he had when he came in he had a giant
big black spot on him and we thought
okay it's a bit a white cat with a giant
spot on him and then over the course of
a week and a half it was an oil slick it
was an oil
it was an oil stain dang and he just
licked it off him and he's a fuzzy
[__] he's so cuddly and he'll
just come up he's like a dog and so far
as he'll come up he's drinking oil
fighting socks he's drinking oil and
during the day he'll sit in your lap and
he'll just like lick he's just the
sweetest animal and then it and then
he's at night if he's he's
so
um one of my kids we have uh out outside
of my bedroom we have like a little
patio outside and then and we're up on
the second floor
and then uh the cat and my kids left the
door a little open and you know those
cats cats are like liquids they're just
like a sheet of paper they can literally
yes so they just left the door just a
tiny bit open and the Cat found his way
out and I watched this whole thing
happen and I was like his name's moose
I'm like moose come on come on so I
chase moose out and he's and now he's on
the roof sure and then he goes up to the
top of the roof where there's a peak
yeah and it's pretty high up and so he's
up on the peak and I'm like I'm not
gonna chase you you go go do whatever
you're gonna do
so I go back inside and then and then I
feel bad I'm like I gotta get the cat
inside so because I I just got to get
them inside I'm afraid something's gonna
happen so I get a can of cat food which
I'll always come back for and he just
hears the sound and he comes running
sure so I I come back out and as I come
back out I call him and I like I took a
fork and I like hit the can
well what happened was when the when I
hit the can I think I made a sound which
blew up a hawk spot I think the hawk was
like like looking at his prey and moose
is still on the peak of the house
he's looking at he was looking at moose
apparently this happened so fast so I
hit it like and then all of a sudden
this Hawk tried to eat this cat the hawk
comes out of the tree which is right in
front I'm watching the high out of I got
a front row seat wow it comes out of the
tree which is right near the peak of my
house the cat is on the edge of the peak
like a gargoyle looking down and the
hawk comes right at him and I saw moose
go
like 17 Jabs in a half a second [__]
Mayweather and the Hawks like [__] this
and then he goes up and he's coming back
down for another dive bomb and I'm
expecting I'm like most expecting him to
come running back in and moose just
stays there and I'm like holy [__] he's
gonna do it again so the cat so the hawk
comes down again and moose takes one
more swipe and that Hawk wanted none of
it and the hawk takes off and then moose
just comes like like running down to me
and then I like open the door and he
stopped right outside the door and sat
right back down outside and I was like
this cat he wants more he wants to [__]
this bring it up yeah so he got a whole
can of cat food there I was like yeah
yeah nice work moose
it was a bat it was insane he should
have named it Marion
marrying the cat so anyway cat versus
cat versus pretty badass dude you should
have filmed it it happened it split yeah
yeah so you want to see those reactions
the reaction videos of snakes and cats
yes where they can that this there was I
saw a video recently it's their reaction
speed it's like a point this close yes
to the cat yes like right and the cat's
just like yep
and then the second that that snake
makes a moves like yeah it's got it's
something about the reaction speeds of
cat of cats are it's .23 milliseconds
we've all seen a snake like do that and
it's faster than that cat-like reflex
cat Library
Hawks also very fast yeah and they have
those giant Talons and this was this
thing came down Falcon fastest animal in
the world fastest animal in the world I
don't know enough about Falcons today no
he's right no it's a peregrine falcon is
the fastest animal on Earth really yes
because it can die back over time
yeah it literally it literally turns
itself into a [__] missile and then
just like launches itself what's the
hawk what's the Hawks move there too the
prey that big I know I think they grab
it they take it and then drop it oh yeah
guess what if he did that moose would
land on his feet yeah and he'd be like
[__] you come down for more bring it
[__] I broke all my [__] words like
surprise wings no idea it's like pop
okay
[__] fly surprise [__] I'm a griffin
thank you